ce matin à Nanterre un mineur de 17 ans
a été tué à bout portant après un
contrôle routier j'adresse bien sûr à la
famille aux proches de la victime non
plus sincères condoléances monsieur le
ministre nous reconnaissons tout comme
vous l'action difficile risquée que même
les forces de l'ordre partout dans notre
pays ils sont bien souvent les premiers
à répondre face aux dangers mais l'usage
des armes ne peut et ne doit se faire
que dans des cas très précis qui
représentent un danger vital pour le
dépositaire de la force publique les
images de Nanterre ce matin sont
terribles contrairement à ce qu'on peut
affirmer certains médias aucun policier
ne se trouvait devant le véhicule
lorsque celui-ci était en mouvement leur
intégrité physique n'était manifestement
pas menacée et le tir à bout portant ne
semble absolument pas proportionné au
délit commis non le jeune homme n'a pas
foncé sur les policiers comme l'affirme
les professionnels de la récupération
politique à l'extrême droite de cette
hémicycle nous avons sur l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux une vidéo des montants
catégoriquement cette version
cette affaire n'est malheureusement pas
isolée pire nous constatons une hausse
des cas comme à Nice ou encore à Paris à
l'automne dernier depuis cela s'accélère
avec deux blessés graves en
Seine-Saint-Denis les 16 mai et 3 juin
et un nouveau tué le 14 juin à Angoulême
ce matin en effet à Nanterre deux
motards de la DOPC de la préfecture de
police on procédés à un contrôle nous ne
connaissons pas sauf les images
extrêmement choquantes ce que j'ai vu
personnellement comme beaucoup de
Français les conditions exactes puisque
les policiers en ce moment sont
auditionnés par les services de justice
deux enquêtes ont été confiées à l'IGPN
et évidemment je veux aussi dire que
c'est un drame que ce jeune conducteur
de 17 ans soit mort des suites de ce
contrôle manifestement mais je ne suis
pas juge je ne suis pas procureur de la
République madame et je veux aussi être
attentif à la présomption des
fonctionnaires de 196 fonctionnaires de
police je pendant cependant madame
permettez-moi de ne pas être totalement
d'accord avec la fin de votre question
depuis la loi 2017 j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire dans de très nombreuses échanges
ici qui a eu moins de tirs et il moins
de cas mortels qu'avant 2017 je suis
désolé madame que dans de très nombreux
cas malheureusement des policiers et des
gendarmes sont morts de refus
d'obtempérer et dans de très nombreux
cas il s'agit pas de mélanger avec celui
de ce matin manifestement ce sont des
familles de policiers et de gendarmes
qui pleurent leurs enfants alors non
bien sûr le fait nous enterrer ne peut
pas être accepté mais il n'est pas non
plus bien évidemment capable d'accepter
que des policiers tirent à vos portant
sur des jeunes hommes ou des jeunes
femmes quel que soit l'âge d'ailleurs
des conducteurs et vous dire qu'on doit
respecter le deuil des familles mais la
présomption d'innocence des policiers